[Music]
in forced breakups news submitted by
chew on this a school is forcing 5th
graders to end their puppy love
relationships to stay focused on this
study yeah [ __ ] absolutely right yeah
good luck but to keep their relationship
alive I need you to hit subscribe right
now because 5th graders have every right
to code deep in their poster getting
nevermind maybe you unsubscribe yeah
that part and then you subscribe the
connection sorry hey everybody should
love 5th graders can love each other
subscribe for love that's right by the
way it when I was in fifth grade I had a
girlfriend too and if someone tried to
separate me from her I'd mother [ __ ]
start World War three I think I was an
insult in fifth grade really I had a
crush on this girl named Melanie and I
only she liked me I got in trouble too
much but then I met her twin sister in
sixth grade Michelle you know like I
know my school like the kids always swap
the classes so by the next grade I was
like Michelle's wait a minute but she
didn't like neither if you were insecure
in the way that I wish you were you you
would in every video or thing that
you're in you'd be like hey Mellie look
at me now but yes so this is happening
in some southern Indiana school
specifically we're talking about one
school here makes sense they get
pregnant out there really early Indiana
with all those Juggalos [ __ ] around
fifth grade they're already popping out
baby Juggalos they already come out with
[ __ ] clown faces and like ICP fans
over there yeah insane clown posse yes
so there's this new policy at Riverside
elementary in Jeffersonville that says
fifth graders aren't allowed to date it
but I can read it to you but fourth
graders are they're like you could have
a you could be a couple up until four
three and six just by grade you got
break up because your grades are [ __ ]
up and then sixth grade you could get
back together because they are only
focusing on fifth grade here so there's
three fifth fifth grade classes
it says dear parents it has come to our
attention that many of the fifth grade
students are dating each other this is
this is the age students become
interested in develop crushes but this
is also the age that hearts can get
broken quickly at this age children are
dating and breaking up with them days of
each other this leads to many broken
hearts which carry into the classroom to
combat students having broken hearts we
have implemented a serious dating policy
we are still encouraging our fifth
graders to have many friends and to
develop strong friendships all three
classes have been spoken to about the
importance of this matter they were
given Tuesday and Wednesday to make sure
that relationships have ended again we
are encouraged how do they even know
who's with exactly they don't stay like
when reporters were asking like how are
you gonna enforce this they don't have
an answer
no [ __ ] they're [ __ ] dog they're
making out our recess will stop that is
that they don't even do that they do
this [ __ ]
oh that's too much that's too much no no
that is too much because at fifth grade
you know what people will do is they
like hey can you tell him you want to be
together yeah there's like a person in
the middle yeah it might be different
now you can't even communicate I don't
know if I see people holding hands I
don't know if they're making out that's
to next looks like fourth base fourth
base a home run well no in that term
according to those rules it's Little
League my favorite heads tits be ball
it's a little bitty little
bass bro she wrote me a love letter with
a kiss on the paper and I kissed the
paper and that was my first kiss first
or no time I don't even know how to do
that for sure still don't know how to do
that one day yeah ah nah I graduated
from this too just yeah Lizzie run away
yeah no wow no one between just no no
belly button
that's what sick dudes do all over you
and you had your first girlfriend uh
maybe it's like childish like oh yeah
that's 12
okay first yeah but like you know baby
boomer huh you're 12 like you know
what's weird
no in this they say that fifth grade is
when people start liking each I like
girls from the moment I stepped into
kindergarten - same here I really like
this girl so like in kindergarten there
was two classes right there was my class
here in another class there but we meet
up for recess in or lunch or whatever
right we would get into the playground
so those all this girl from this other
class something about her man I was so
like I don't know what it is about her
right and then one time she was playing
house with another boy and and then I
saw her she kept [ __ ] squeezing her
body up like that and she was like stop
and I was thinking oh she doesn't want
you to do that I want to do that and
then like I was in kindergarten but I
remember kinky like don't do that and
then like and then I was like [ __ ] I
feel like I should say something and it
cuz she kept like like pushing him off
right and I was like [ __ ] I'm gonna do
it yeah and then and then like as soon
as I came up I was like [ __ ] I don't
know what to say and I was like can i
play too
and then that's that's it Joe's like
guys feeling this chick up yeah it was
like hey you get your hands off her and
then he comes up and he's like yeah
laughs we get to the boy and that was my
first experience of like jealousy and
like juanny like oh man like I want to
[ __ ] him touch her - that's [ __ ] up
laughing yeah but it's like I don't know
what was going on in my head I was like
that's boyfriend stuff he's not your
boyfriend but then even at that age you
know it's wrong like he's not supposed
to do that unless she's okay with it
yeah you could feel that it's wrong for
some reason yeah dude was a girl that I
liked since kindergarten my name is Amy
and in the third grade I found out that
she liked me and it was the best two
weekends of my life you guys just know
you like each other yeah yeah we didn't
do that they don't know well no we got
together or whatever like through cuz
we're different classes remember so we
got together per se but then she dumped
me for this other guy like in two weeks
how does she dump you did she tell you
she told me through a very it was like
friends because he was a great older
than me I was in third he was in fourth
and we never saw each other I don't even
know how he even knew I existed because
we had different recess times you guys
have a pedophile line excuse me like
look at my elementary school in the
middle of your story pedophile line so
am i school
fourth fifth and sixth had recess so
first second and third at recess so if
your fourth and third that's big no no
that's that's like oh sorry school it
was like that you caught the pedophile
line the fourth graders like in the
third grader in a different recess
you're the white guy - that was my first
boyfriend nice Wow
so that's the only time you did it at
wipers that one and I never once spoke
to him what guy you dated was a
pedophile you I was I wish you could
have given white a real chance you
didn't even give white a real chance he
was white okay I was I was madly in love
with someone that was I never was like
in proximity with whee
just remembered sorry my second
boyfriend was the white guy it was Kevin
how you guys work together together we
did talk oh yeah what's his house one
weekend oh you sleep so you cross the
barrier he had a birthday party present
any guys they had macaroni and cheese
did you have a cut so so in your
relationship I want to see how similar
this is did you did you have your
designated friends send messages back
and forth yeah mm-hmm wait no back then
we were writing notes and then the can
you tell can you tell her these are the
things these are the reasons why like
she says that she likes you too
okay because you have good hair and you
look over and she's like oh and you see
a group of friends and [ __ ] and then the
thing was I was her brother's friend and
then her brother would be like the
consigliere in [ __ ] - right but when I
come over like she would never hang on
I'm like what the [ __ ] I got my heart
broken cuz I was like when are we
actually gonna [ __ ] hang out right
and then I was like asking her brother
like hey like how come she doesn't want
to play with us and like hang out with
us and he goes oh man I don't know like
she's - like what he's shy or nervous
and I was like what does she say about
me
and he would tell me like oh she's crazy
about you man she only says this and
this and this and I'm like how come
she's lying she doesn't want to be with
me and I got heartbroken and I broke it
off because I was like getting insecure
because she doesn't want to hang out but
look at all the lessons that you learn
from doing all that [ __ ] I didn't learn
[ __ ] you did these are getting surprises
that [ __ ] what [ __ ] weird if great
look at what the one that's the the kid
one-night-stands
be like in fourth grade or fifth day
right like the fourth grade or fifth
grade where like you guys go to a
birthday party so it's like different
from school right and then you guys are
all hanging out and then as like some
kids are able to stay later some go and
then I could check that you never really
thought you would connect with all of a
sudden you guys
and then like the whole night it's just
amazing you're like oh my god it's like
I'm in a Disney movie right and then
you're like oh my for sure we're gonna
be together next day at school and ask
her to be my girlfriend and the next day
you go to school you're like hi and
she's just like but you did it I had
that same [ __ ] happen that's crazy so
sad except I was in high school she just
hit it and quit oh yeah
what did she hit it she hit your
attention and credit yeah I think we
play like monopoly together and we have
that moment and that is gone I was
probably in that group that left never
better
the sad part is when you're like hey we
could get together maybe move away
monopoly again she's like yeah we could
whatever and it's like we had a moment I
mean like monopoly I'm like but we
playing for three hours she's like
what's a long game you're playing with
me a monopoly
[Music]